so job not well done by the people that
missed out
on luther well you're talking about two
teams then including this one here as uh
booker gets to the rim
and lays it in first points for devin
booker
and booker scoops up the loose ball
pull up three is good for booker
diving to the cup offensive foul clearly
and i love what devin booker he named
first team all nba in either his first
or second year
since tim duncan back in 1999.
booker hangs and finishes beautifully
done by devin booker now nine points
hit a couple of shots though finished
with
seven in the quarter but devin booking
to improve this year think about it he
averaged 29
a game last year while shooting 32
percent from three
what happens when he gets that shooting
percentage around 40. prove this year
think about it he averaged
29 a game last year while shooting 32
percent from three
what happens when he gets that shooting
percentage assists for doncic he
averaged nine per game last year good
for third in the nba
here's booker with the hanging finish 13
points for devin booker his first
bucket of the second quarter 15 shots
bridges had 15 booker 13 for the suns
who have an eight-point lead
in the season opener in game one 38
in game six although the mavs just
didn't have enough
as chris paul gets his first points as a
son
last time chris paul had this matchup he
missed the three this time
so allow me to have this dance
four-point lead for phoenix paul gets
into the paint
trying to create some space and he hits
that fall away
here's booker and devin booker with
another three ball
here's what you were talking about guys
with the ability to make
shots in the nba after a strong showing
in the bubble for the suns when they won
8-0 he was a big part of that
nice pass there by payne to booker who
gets the layup
comes with five you got to do a better
job protecting the paint when you allow
them
[Music]
paul with a pull-off jumper that's sweet
and the latest three
look at the leadership on the floor and
off
most you need a basket shot clock at
five
big possession here for the suns booker
with two
heads over brunson he puts his team in
position and puts his home run
hidden in position to take a big shot
great defense by jalen brunson but
better offense by devin booker